what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so at the time that I'm recording this
video right now I just finished watching
the flash and Connor was an amazing
episode I'm not going to spoil it for
anybody who hasn't seen it yet although
the video is probably gonna be going up
today
fYI actually record my videos about a
week before you guys see them and
sometimes I'll upload them and make them
unlisted and then people will just be
like a secret city you know like they'll
find it and they'll be super excited
which by the way I've actually got a
video on my channel no one's found it
yet and I'm curious to see whether or
not you guys can find it but I have a
video about my channel that's been up
for a month and no one knows that it's
there like it's kind of funny I was just
testing to see how it is you guys find
my secret videos and it's and it's kind
of weird but anyway so after reading the
Free Comic Book Day version are is
really their Free Comic Book Day release
of Captain America's secret Empire what
I wanted to do is I really want to come
and go back a little bit because with
with secret Empire I mean you really
could just pick up with all-new
all-different marvel just kind of start
with The Avengers and then read like you
know Avengers vol 1 and then like
Captain America Sam Wilson vol 1 then
Avengers stand off and then Captain
America Steve Rogers you could go in on
order and read those stories but in
truth I think it all really kind of
dates back to Rick Remender run the
reason why I'm doing this is because of
the fact that for those are the guys who
are new to Captain America
you know like Hydra Captain America is
the first time you picked them up I want
you guys to be able to have a sort of
foundation I want you guys to be able to
look and to see why there are so many
people who are up in arms about Captain
America and I feel like Rick Remender
run it starts really with Steve Rogers
being trapped in dimension Z and then
coming back and then fighting iron ale
and losing the Super Soldier Serum and
getting old I think a lot of those
things really kind of encapsulate what
makes Captain America what he is so for
the next three weeks or so we're going
to run through all that stuff it'll be
like every other day or something like
that I mean we're back to alternating
all-new all-different marvel and DC
rebirth every other day of the week so
it'll come pretty fast like I mean we'll
roll through it and within a week and a
half but initially just kind of picks up
with the Lower East Side of Manhattan in
1926 and it picks up with the early days
of Captain America now a lot of people
have really redone Captain America's
origin in a lot of ways for example
Captain America White was an amazing
story by by Jeph Loeb I keep forgetting
it was an amazing story by Jeph Loeb and
it
really really good to kind of take a
look at Captain America I mean you know
Tim's sales are was you know really cool
and everything but the Badger man's here
that with Captain America's origin kind
of being revamped so to speak here by
Rick Remender what it does is it gives
us a basis behind why he is the way he
is and over the years this has been done
in different ways we differen people
have done it in different forms but the
common theme among the traditional
Captain America that you think of is
that he is a guy who stands up for those
that can't stand up for himself and
again while the origins could have been
redone and not a lot of people know the
specifics about what he was before he
became Captain America it was always
just kind of taken us that's what he is
that's what he's about he's the guy that
stands up for the weak what we end up
getting here is we end up basically
finding out that his father you know
growing up in the Great Depression was a
very abusive man now I wouldn't go as
far as to say that he's like every other
man during the Great Depression I don't
know enough about individual
personalities during that era to make
that claim but what I can say is the
father of Steve Rogers was probably one
of several people out there you know
just having common sense that would tell
us what he basically lashed out at those
of us around him because keep in mind
during the Great Depression and
especially around that era the man was
the breadwinner I mean this was really
kind of long before World War two was
long before women were able to step into
the age of having jobs in the workplace
and running companies and so on and so
forth and so for the father of Steve
Rogers it was a pride thing it was a
sense that he just wasn't really able to
make the kind of money that he needed in
order to provide for his family
adequately now on the surface it seems
like an admirable thing but it's not and
the reason why is because in his anger
and in his irritation and his
frustration with his lot in life
he turns to alcohol and he abuses his
wife now Steve Rogers you know basic
kind of watches a lot of these things
unfold and we're not really given an
indication here at least initially by
Rick Remender that Steve Rogers father
takes his hands to Steve himself but his
mother keeps standing up keeps basically
getting back up again and refuses to
fall down now this is not Rick Remender
saying oh yeah in feminism and so on
it's not like that what it is is it's
giving Rogers the foundation because he
asks his mother why didn't you just stay
down and she replies because you always
stand back up no matter what happens you
always stand on your feet that is the
core of what makes Captain America what
he is and people who are fans of the
traditional Captain America are probably
like
certain by that little bit of a
description probably kind of heartened
by that like yes that is Captain America
he is the guy that always stands back up
he will fight until the bitter end now
of course this kind of transitions to
the modern day when he's just fighting
some guy called green skull I'm usually
just like a crazy environmentalist guy
he just wants to detonate some kind of
bomb on earth or you know in Manhattan
little like you know hyper evolved
plants and turn people into plants and
with its weirdest nonsensical this is a
design to be some great big huge story
or thing its design designed to be
pretty based I mean you know the guys
defeated pretty quickly he's handed over
to the cops and that's the end of that
Steve Rogers goes to meet Sharon Carter
now a little bit of an exposition here
Sharon Carter's kind of had a weird
history over the course of Marvel Comics
there was a point where she was the
daughter of Peggy Carter and then she
was the niece of Peggy Carter and a lot
of that kind of stuff was basically
changed up because of the chronology of
Peggy herself but the fact remains here
that with Peggy Carter having been the
love interest of Captain America during
World War two and the fact that it just
wasn't plausible it wasn't practical to
have the two of them together let's play
sixty years later or something like that
when you know in the modern day it made
more sense to pair Steve Rogers off with
Sharon Carter so the two of them have
been a couple for quite some time and
really the relationship has kind of
evolved to the point where they're
talking about the idea of marriage now
for Steve Rogers and really what Rick
Remender does here is he basically
provides the circumstance where Steve's
just kind of like I don't know and it's
really kind of cool because he plays on
the hero archetype of Steve Rogers and
he really kind of gives us this idea
that Rogers doesn't really know how to
be a regular person in World War two
because I mean you have to think about
it from his perspective he grew up with
an abusive father so we had this
intrinsic drive to protect those that
couldn't protect themselves that became
a reality when he became Captain America
he fought in World War two he fought
alongside the invaders was frozen in ice
for some 20 years he was thought out he
joined the Avengers and all he's done is
fight as a superhero since he's never
been able to sit down and kind of eel
let his hair down so to speak and just
be a normal human being it's always been
one adventure after the next the earth
is in danger New York is in danger the
universe is in danger there's always
been something going on that requires
him to be a superhero
and so when presented with the
opportunity to just be a man it's almost
scary
it's almost was kind of like exploring
this new part of himself that he's never
really had a chance to explore before
now all this doesn't really matter
anyway because of the fact that when he
gets on the subway train he just kind of
whisked away two dimensions II
now we're not really told how we're just
kind of told that he is uninsured it's
just sort of a it's a transition piece
it doesn't need to be super in-depth but
his arrival is met with Armand Zola he's
basically kind of knocked out he subdued
and he wakes up in a lab now something
to point out here is that Arnim Zola
being here in dimension Z as just a
byproduct of the landscape of Marvel
Comics after house of them which is to
say a lot of the characters are just
kind of revamped and they were adjusted
and they were kind of given new stories
and different things like that and so
quantum Zola was just kind of vacant for
something like eight years you know
intimately he showed up here but with
regards to him having a robot body
this was actually fleshed out of a had
been established and Marvel for quite
some time but it was basically fleshed
out in invaders now written by Christos
Gage and drawn by Alex Ross it's an
absolutely beautiful beautiful story but
what it does is it focuses on the
invaders during World War two like we
said you know Captain America Bucky
Barnes Jim Hammond and name of the
Submariner but the idea was that you
know when one more to Arnim Zola was
just a guy he was just a crazy scientist
guy but eventually his physical body was
destroyed and he basically kept his own
mind intact in the form of a robot and
this is how he functioned for years and
years and years it was away from Marvel
to kind of keep his character going with
him staying a villain without having the
Super Soldier Serum and just kind of
keeping him alive because after a while
if he didn't have a Super Soldier serum
or the infinity serum which is what Nick
Fury had in order to keep himself young
partum Zola would just grow old and
eventually die so just for the sake of
practicality he was just kind of given
given a robot body but the fact remains
here that we also know finding out that
that Arnim Zola is basically growing a
child in an incubation team now this is
a young boy that he's basically kind of
growing into his own for the purpose of
absorbing that are taking the Super
Soldier Serum out of Captain America and
putting it in this child of course
Captain America is able to free himself
any takes this boy along with him we
also end up learning that Arnim Zola
also has a young girl named jet black
now in truth these are not children that
he had biologically produced with any
particular woman they're basically grown
they're engineered by Arnim Zola as is
everything within dimension Z dimension
Zola all this stuff belongs to him ships
the aliens a whole nine yards now a lot
of them were created and then just kind
of set out in the environment and they
were more or less just left there but
the idea is that in the midst of the
explosion Zola cannot find a child
cannot find his son and so his initial
thought is Captain America basically
killed him in the explosion but of
course
no Captain America took the boy with him
and so those of you guys who were
reading a little bit about Captain
America about him having a son that's
where this comes from
it comes from the whole dimension Z what
he basically rescues the child or takes
the child from Zola now the reason for
this is just Steve Rogers kind of being
a reasonable human being in the sense
that if Zola has a child under his
control it hits at home for Steve Rogers
Zola is a bad guy and he will basically
turn this child into a villain for all
intents and purposes so because of that
Rogers is both serving is kind of a
guardian of this child and a surrogate
father in a sympathy names and Ian and
he even goes as far as to say that for
the year that they've been there because
we actually jumped forward by about a
year the year that they've been there
they're learning new things all the time
Steve Rogers is basically learning about
this entire play she's learning that you
know you have to be a really successful
hunter you have to learn to be able to
fend off on your own but the issue with
this is that this basically contradicts
directly with his desire to return home
because every waking dream that he has
every nightmare that he has is always
about the idea of getting back home to
Sharon Carter the problem with this is
that what in his chest he has this
constant nagging pain now this is going
to be kind of a recurring theme this
nagging burning sensation in his hand is
going to be an ongoing theme that
happens with regards to him you know
trying to cope with what's going on but
for the most part things are pretty
straightforward in the sense that he and
his son are just trying to navigate
throughout the different territories of
dimension Z and they come across
different races they come across
different groups you know for example
they end up coming across a group that
calls themselves the frogs now the frogs
are just one of the various species that
exist in dimension Z that serve the
purpose of just kind of opposing Arnim
Zola now they do not launch like
campaigns against Zola just because of
the fact that you know with regards to
Zola's you know sphere of influence and
is the capital city and so on and so
forth they just don't have the abilities
to fend off against it but what
recommenders doing here is he's
basically saying this is just one of
those circumstances where we've stumbled
across a race that's just kind of grown
unto itself and that's really what Zola
did Zola would basically he was like a
like a prime mover he would create these
species he would set their evolution in
motion and then whatever happened
happened but again they were just kind
of designed in a way to where he could
monitor them to a degree but he did also
those kind of rule over a land of his
own now in the end Zola's goal is to
also basically take over her time as you
know to invade the earth with his force
so on and so forth but we end up finding
that there's actually some some trouble
in paradise here there's some strife
among the ruling class of the Proxima
Centauri derp is really more of a tyrant
and he's been led then he's led his
people to believe but it's also this
idea that he's kind of getting in to the
existing rule of zola which is to say
but he's not really leading a revolution
now of course a Steve Rogers is able to
activate a universal translator that was
previously given to him by Hank Pym and
is able to understand what it is that
they're saying and this is where we end
up finding there's kind of a debate
between the various members of the Fox
in a sense that some of them view Steve
Rogers as a liberator as a guy that
opposes Arnim Zola and can in turn help
them be liberated from Arnim Zola others
view him as a guy who sides with Zola
and is more of a spy now ultimately
those that view Rogers in a positive
light end up coming out on top and me as
the end result as it he actually takes
up residence with him to being by the
name of Zhou Shore and his wife and the
result is that he's kind of Todd you
know how to survive he's taught how to
fish taught the tools or the skills that
he needs in order to make it in
dimension Z but ultimately this leads
directly to a conflict between us off
shore and some of the other experienced
Eve Rogers chimes in and says look if
you don't like Zola then rise up against
him now ultimately you know the response
is that nobody else wants to fight
against a Zola just because of the
forces that he has and so on and so
forth but ultimately what ends up taking
place here is Roger says what all it
takes is one guy again kind of harkening
back to the lesson that his mother
taught him if you live on your knees
you're going to be forced to exist on
your knees you know you're going to be
forced to serve other people but if you
stand up and you die fighting then maybe
you'll become a martyr for something
else now this brings in a lot of
philosophical ideas about the nature of
conflict right I mean right now in in
secret Empire Captain America is the
tyrant you know Steve Rogers as an agent
of Hydra is the bad guy now we'll cross
that bridge in terms of retcons and so
on once we get to Avenger stand off but
for the time being it brings in a lot of
these philosophical arguments you know
for example people will say well martyrs
went Wars well not really because
they're dead oars are won by the people
who fight long enough to win the war it
creates this kind of plenty situation
but then again what motivation would
they have to fight if they weren't led
by a martyr if they weren't inspired by
the actions of the motor so it was
really kind of like all these different
themes come together to lead to a
conflict as we know it
again this agony in his chest this
searing pain in his chest the
experiences time and time again once he
basically makes his escape is revealed
to be Arnim Zola who planted himself
inside the body of Steve Rogers now
again this is kind of weird because this
is what Zola does Zola will basically
jump from one host body to the next in
order to keep himself alive now he still
has his physical body I mean he still
has that that robotic body but keeping
himself alive in Steve Rogers will allow
him to defeat Steve Rogers and the
reason why is because of the fact that
fighting Captain America is not just a
physical battle I mean it is in a lot of
different ways if you're super strong
Captain America is not going to be able
to face off against you The Incredible
Hulk versus Steve Rogers in a legit
fight Rogers is going to lose every
single time it doesn't matter what his
tactical experience is but when it comes
to facing off against Captain America
somebody like Arnim Zola uses
psychological advantage and that's what
it is basically you know we end up
picking up 11 years after this
revelation again you know Rick Remender
kind of jumps us forward and we end up
finding out that with with armed Zola
inside the body of Steve Rogers he
constantly talks to him he constantly
taunts him now the reason why this is
significant is because of the fact that
Arnim Zola as he exists in Steve Rogers
is more or less equivalent to the
techno-organic virus now for those of
you guys who don't know in Marvel Comics
the techno-organic virus is basically a
virus that converts organic tissue into
machinery
it's what's attached to cable it's what
makes cable half of a robot he uses his
telekinetic and telepathic powers to
constantly keep the virus at bay that's
why he's not as powerful as he could be
that's why stripe is so much more calm
from the cable because stripe is
basically cable cloned without the
techno-gang virus so he's everything
cable could be but the fact remains here
that within the realm of this particular
story Arnim Zola is basically a virus
constantly trying to take over the body
of Captain America the difference here
is that Captain America doesn't really
have a tried-and-true way of suppressing
Arnim Zola with the exception of
whatever healing factor his Super
Soldier Serum offers and maybe whatever
kind of you know mental control he can
exert over his body if any at all and so
because of that Zola is just slowly
taking over the body of Steve Rogers but
along the way what he's trying to do is
he's coming to grips with the fact that
he might die now of course he knows that
if he gets back home if it gets back to
the main Marvel Universe that he'll be
able to go with the Avengers and they'll
be able to remove Zola and the day will
be safe but on the
chance that he doesn't make it on the
off chance that he ends up dying he's
passing all these important lessons onto
in and doing the best you can basically
telling them you have to fight for those
who can't fight for themselves you have
to work for those who who are basically
trying to save themselves you know we're
trying to become a better person your
role is to be a hero and to be a leader
instead of a conqueror now of course
this also coincides with Arnim Zola
basically talking to Rogers about the
true heritage of Ian and the reason why
is because ian has grown up believing
that Steve Rogers is his father and
whenever the question was asked what did
I come from where's my mother Rogers
would always dodge the question he would
always divert his attention to something
else and as a child you know as a pretty
young kid Ian never really had a reason
to ask any questions but now he's in his
teenage years and the result is that
he's a little more angsty he's a little
more rebellious he wants answers to the
questions that he's been asking but had
been denied him for so long
and so because of that ultimately we
have Arnim Zola kind of speaking out on
behalf of Steve Rogers essentially
saying you were grown into the laughs
you are a kid who is basically just kind
of created you don't really belong to
Steve Rogers you're not his biological
son you're just kind of there now of
course this is crushing for Ian and this
is actually going to be one of the
reasons why in effectively defects from
Steve Rogers which leads into their
second half which is escape from
dimensions II but the fact remains here
that we also end up picking up with jet
black now again jet black is basically
the daughter of Arnim Zola as we saw
earlier in the story the problem here is
that recomendar does not really expand
much on her character in terms of what
she's capable of all we know is that my
virtue of the trials the xi8 experience
which are basically the legend she
learns engaging in different combat
scenarios honing her skills she has what
are called omni senses now the idea here
is that she can basically transform any
one of her five senses into omni sense
so here i gets elevated - omnis
including elevated to the height of its
ability so she wanted to elevate her
sense of smell to the to its highest
point
she literally takes away from all the
other senses so she diminishes all four
other senses down to zero so they're
simple smell can be at its peak but she
also has like enhanced strength and
different things like that but again a
lot of these things aren't really given
to us she said we just in and don't now
and has these different powers and
that's really about it now she's also a
prodigious fighter he can also see
slightly into the future and so she
knows the moves
to make before they make them now of
course this also leads directly into her
her motivation in the sense that she
like Arnim Zola believed that their son
is dead and so remember Arnim Zola
inside Steve Rogers is a totally
different being than Arnim Zola the
robot they do not communicate they do
not talk they have no way of knowing the
other ones there so the best example I
can give is like from Harry Potter right
Voldemort one of the Horcrux is the the
diarrhea of Tom Riddle was able to act
totally separate in and of itself but
Baltimore didn't know about it he
couldn't talk to it he wasn't tell you
know telepathically aware of what was
going on it was just a totally separate
entity so again it's really kind of a
that's the best example that I can think
of off the top of my head you know
spur-of-the-moment but the fact remains
here that ultimately we end up finding
the frocks leading somewhat of a revolt
but not by choice what we end up finding
out is that arm Zola basically sent his
forces out across the landscape to find
Captain America now again this is
basically him alongside a jet black
going out to get revenge on Captain
America because in their mind
Captain America led to the death of
arnim zola's son and jet blacks brother
and so because of that the fight is
relatively short-lived in the sense that
we end up seeing them you know kind of
hold their own but the other half of
this is that Captain America inspired a
lot of these members of the frocks to
basically fight as best they can and so
while Captain America and Ian jump into
the fray Steve Rogers comes into the
direct conflict with the jet black now
this is when we get that little bit of
an explanation by recomendar in terms of
what she's capable of but again it's
really only situational it's not super
complex it's not super in-depth it's
only really this scenario where Steve
Rogers doesn't understand why she's so
fast he doesn't understand why she's
able to predict his moves before she
before he makes them but that's really
it I mean there's not a whole lot doing
here the ability for Steve Rogers to
make his getaway comes into play when we
end up having Ian making his presence
known and Ian basically showing himself
to jet black means that as far as she's
aware now he's very much alive and so
what ends up happening here is Captain
America uses the opportunity to
basically grab in and get out of there
now of course this comes after the
conflict between Arnim Zola and and
Captain America himself but again
basically making his escape kind of
stumbling away the last action that he
takes here the fact that he has this
little items all inside his body
the last action that he takes here it's
the basically grab a knife to
essentially gut himself and cut this
thing directly
out of his in size and so it's kind of
gruesome it's kind of screwed up but
this shows us how ruthless Captain
America can be when it comes to really
achieving his goal but it also shows us
how dark dimensions he is that he's
really kind of being forced to revert to
some pretty base instincts to some
pretty based forms it's just meant to
show us that Steve Rogers is doing what
it takes in order to get out of
dimension Z proper but with that being
said guys if you are new near the
comments explained make sure you have
the sub button to become part of the
robb fork if you enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you guys later please
[Music]